c'est parti jusqu'au printemps 2024 un
chantier de déconstruction immense et
complexe
et c'est du côté de l'île des soeurs que
l'ancien pont champlain a commencé à
disparaître en tout 3,4 km d'asphalt de
béton et d'acier seront démantelés
segment par segment ya pas d'explosifs
on est vraiment dans un démantèlement
délicat pièce par pièce de façon à
minimiser les factions des citoyens
l'impact sur l'environnement également
parmi les contraintes le démantèlement
de la grande structure métallique au
dessus de la voie maritime
cette étape ne pourra se faire qu'en
hiver lorsque la circulation des navires
est arrêté et ce ne sera pas en 2021
mais les travaux ailleurs sur l'eau et
commenceront au printemps ce soit
vraiment des travaux encore plus
complexes ont déçu de l'eau ça c'est
certain
donc il va avant tout le travail qui va
se faire sur des marges de façon
justement à recueillir les matériaux sur
des barges et à minimiser aussi de tout
ce qui va tomber dans le fleuve
saint-laurent le pont aurait eu 58 ans
seulement cette année mais il est
tellement usé qu'il était impensable de
le conserver pour en faire une grande
promenade par exemple ce pôle a de la
difficulté à supporter son propre poids
donc et les coûts d'entretien serez
faramineux s'est passé pas envisageable
rares sont les automobilistes qui vont
s'ennuyer même les cyclistes rencontré
ce matin sur l'estacade était bien
content du début des travaux bonnes
affaires pourquoi il faut qu'ils des
phases parce que l'eau ça s'empêche te
dois voir la beauté de l'autre ça donne
la possibilité de vraiment améliorer le
secteur et ses pieds surtout l'accès au
fleuve qui montréal pour une île
entourée d'eau il ya très peu d'accès
le réaménagement des berges à l'île des
soeurs et à brossard sera d'ailleurs
inclus dans le chantier de 400 millions
de dollars
une facture qui comprend aussi le
recyclage de la grande majorité des
matériaux
il y en a pour près de 300 mille tonnes
ici jean sébastien cloutier radio canada
montréal